obsolete eeeh was your first feature
film let's talk about Sundance a blind
submission you know anyone there what
happened Sundance was a submission on
the last day of submissions and it was
walked in not posted or FedExed I walked
it in by myself I didn't trust anybody
else to do it
that day Diane and I had been given two
tickets to go and see the Dalai Lama
talk and it was the last day end of
submissions and I said today and you go
and see the Dalai Lama I'm gonna go and
deliver the film over to Sundance Diane
went and saw the Dalai Lama I went and
delivered the film at Sundance and when
I got there that the performer is is
that it's in a manila envelope with a
particular code number written on top
that you deliver to the counter and then
that person at the counter of the office
in Sundance's office in Beverly Hills
they take that envelope and put it in
the pile and I watched where it went in
the pile and I looked at the pile and I
was a gas at the amount of envelopes
that were standing upright all the way
down this corridor and I thought to
myself well there goes nothing because
there were so many envelopes I just
didn't think we had a chance so yeah we
did not know we knew nobody there we
just gave in a blind submission then
when the programmers got to it it was in
a slush pile and the guy had watched for
movies previously and this was his fifth
movie to watch and that was exactly how
it was selected for competition at
Sundance
he watched four movies and then he got
to ours which you've seen our movie it's
pretty slow I mean there's less cuts in
our movie than there is in a 60 second
car commercial you know so he watched
our movie after watching four of the
movies and then
he decided that it was going to go into
another pile which was further up the
food chain and that was how we got into
competition at Sundance and we I so we
knew absolutely nobody and we really I
mean we didn't have high expectations we
just felt like it was worth submitting
you know as you do and it was the first
thing we submitted it to the film was
not finished we had done we had not
completed sound at that time it was not
color corrected and so yes we said those
things to do and then I was out in
Wyoming and you know this is like a
couple months later and I was working
with director on a script there and I
was it was funny it's just that funny
thing with timing like I just had this
one night where I really like for the
first time I actually really doubted how
we had made the film and what the film
was and the whole time making it and you
know in post everything I just all the
time I've just I loved it and I loved
the process and I was just like this is
it this is great and whatever happens it
doesn't matter this has been amazing and
I've learned so much and I've grown so
much and what happens beyond this is
it's all fine and this one particular
night you know I just had this night
where I was like and I'm out Wyoming I'm
in the middle of nowhere and I haven't
seen anyone and I'm sure that fed into
it where I was just like Diane you've
screwed up you know like you know like
the movie you should have thought you
should have been more clever you know
you should have got the name cast and
you should have done this and you should
have done it you'll never get to do it
again you'll never make another movie
and the very next day I got up and there
was an email from Sundance saying you
know it's just a number that we can
contact you at and I remember I called
you and then I called Matt and I was
like they're probably just calling they
probably just want to call to say like
you know thanks well done try again next
time do you know like I really was like
you know it can't it can't be actually
you know and then I got that call and it
was I described it recently in my blog I
mean I literally when it was sherry free
Lowe who called me one of the
programmers and I mean when she said you
know your film has been selected I was
literally sort of on the floor crying
and I think because I just had this
really dark night you know this you know
I think I just been in that moment of
going you know you did screw it up
and it's it's it's never gonna be seen
anywhere and then and then that call
came
so with rebel heart films and your your
classes that you're teaching that you're
going on the road I think you're going
to Seattle first is that Seattle first
yeah what do you plan to tell other
filmmakers about that same type of
moment where hey it's the last day and
I've got tickets to go see the Dalai
Lama do I do I take the chance and
submit and how do my how do I know my
film is actually ready you know no I
mean you said it wasn't color corrected
and the sound wasn't yeah okay the sound
was and I think like to be honest
festivals like Sunday's I think they're
really used to seeing films in that sort
of condition you know so I think like if
it's you know if the cut is finished
like you've edit you know you've edited
you've lost picture and you've just got
like some things like some technical
sound color to do like I think they'll
be able to tell from that if it's a film
that's for them that year you know I
also believe in another angle of this
question the the bigger the festival I
believe the more seasoned and informed
the programmers and I think they're able
to discern between something that's
really truly unique and has a voice or a
quality that speaks and they can see
that in first viewing in something
that's not color corrected that's not
that sound properly done that doesn't
have music and all of the accoutrements
that go would have finished film I think
really high-end
bigger festivals that's not to disparage
smaller festivals because we've been to
some great small festivals around the
world not just in America but around the
world the bigger festivals have a more
it seems like a more seasoned more
informed programmers who do this for a
living this is their profession and as a
profession they're able to they're able
to weed out you know the
good from the bad it's also I think that
they're looking for something like
authentic something that's unique
something that's true and something that
certainly the programs at Sundance said
to me you know they said like when we
watch table solidia they said you just
see is pure love you know and you know I
was so moved when one of them said that
to me that is how we made the film right
it was there was never a cynical
decision like it was always that thing
we're sort of like here's the smart
thing to do right here's what
conventional wisdom would have you do
and we always went but it's not right
for us so we're gonna do it like this
you know so we're gonna cast our best
friend in the lead role we're not going
to you know go with the more named
actress we know we're disc it and we
just did everything in that sort of way
and I think that that is ultimately what
gave it the chance to stand out you know
I think those programmers see thousands
of movies and they see thousands of
movies that are trying to get into
Sundance you know and I think our film
wasn't trying to get in Sunday our film
was just trying to be its own weird
unique thing right which some people are
gonna love and some people gonna hate
you know because it's just what it is
but it's certainly none of the decisions
we made in that movie we're sort of
geared towards how do we impress the
programmers at Sundance or how do we get
a movie into there and I think one of
the problems for a lot of films and
something you know to me that really is
a message that we want to impart people
through rebel heart is just that thing
about be true to yourself like make the
film that you will love you know and
trust in that don't try and second-guess
what you think the program is at
Sundance are like you're gonna like
don't in therefore go oh well we'll get
this person because she was in another
movie at Sundance two years ago and oh
we'll get this music because you know
they're really popular and people will
think that you know don't do any of that
like really just you know it's like it's
like filtering out the noise in yourself
to just find your own heart and your own
true story and I really feel like when
you do that and if you do that with an
authentic intent that is how you're
gonna make a film that's gonna stand out
and that's how you're gonna make a film
that will get into Sundance for instance
you know but the more that you're
thinking in a cynical way or I mean you
know sort of a manipulative way I just
think that's a theythey earth out you
know five thousand movies
and most of them are doing that
you